[Music]
some of the many advantages of living
next is the fact that when you want to
go for a run I can hand this morning he
gets run by the heat I hit the river so
exercise can become more of an important
part of my schedule recently I think
partly it's just like whoo I think at
the PhD not in the office because this
is a good thinking time but also weight
loss as I talked about before and it's
kind of the summer I don't know I don't
have to be that fat guy in pictures next
to live you know she's gonna vote hard I
go look hot two cents st. K run first
another Wednesday cool business its head
under the run it's got a locked pub pub
is now there's the reason to go for a
morning run an active athlete beautiful
morning it's not my fastest performance
ever on a 10k but I wasn't really going
to speed also it's kind of aching from
yesterday because I had to try and keep
pace with live for the entire time we
were swimming and choose which is pretty
fast swimmer incidentally if you are a
runner running with bluetooth headphones
we don't worry about the cables jangling
around having your phone on your arm and
like a strap off like a dream highly
highly recommend getting a pair of like
cheap bluetooth headphones that makes
such a difference
[Music]
so this morning I've been poking around
in the stuff I did yesterday and kind of
tweaking little improvements the main
thing I'm doing today is rewriting the
meet of the inversion software that I've
written in Fortran up until now it's
been in Python which completes the kind
of resolution I'm running at it does
about 50 iterations in about two minutes
which is pretty slow the same software
that's written in Fortran will probably
do about two and a half thousand
iterations in ten seconds so I'm
definitely saving a lot of time in the
long run by doing this but it's the
first kind of big program I've written
in Fortran I'm rather than just going in
and tweaking what someone else has
written so that's pretty cool for
transcloud weird language is actually a
limit on how long individual lines can
be because it's totally low-level
language which yeah it's like it's this
number I'll put it on the screen this
medicinally characters long if you want
to Karen or light then you have to put a
carrot like a one on the specific column
of the next line and then that tells the
compiler that oh yo if C stop is not
done yet please you ask I do all my
coding in sublime text 3 now in sublime
text which I highly recommend for coding
get the full version it's genuinely one
of those things that's worth buying the
license or
[Music]
[Music]
so that was a pretty successful
afternoon of Fortran actually I yeah I
had a bit for war violence and the
confidence about the project earlier
again today which is like the fifth time
this week but so that actually was
really good definitely feel like things
are taking over and fingers crossed
tomorrow going to add the new stuff to
the four transcript I added to Python
earlier this week and we'll see what
that does and now it's time for a day
with a girlfriend
guess which one of us went for a run
this morning and here we are again it's
like I've never left I did it I don't
think they thought this through some guy
who by
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
seeing this it's such a nice morning
living I thought we take the scenic
route to work which means going through
this valley that's right by uni but it's
alright I guess pretty nice
I took the photo for Chapel choirs debut
album in a field up there at like 4:00
in the morning happy memories
[Music]
something that I don't know if I've ever
talked about is just how pretty campuses
particularly in summer and actually used
to be the campus it wasn't Arboretum as
like a tree tree zoo they really keep it
enclosures but yeah like it's so so
green the whole campus is absolutely
beautiful and particularly in summer
like picnicking out here it's pretty
great
all right it is just gone past past six
I've been in the office since nine for
nine really productive day actually I've
been failing in Fortran and adding in
functionality today I want to talk about
something which I've been asked about a
couple of times which is the apps and
software that I use in my PhD so I've
already mentioned that I write on in
sublime text I'm doing coding which I
highly recommend for coding I code up by
thesis inlay tech which is by far the
industry standard for doing it science
while certainly earth sciences PhD the
idea of doing my PhD like anything else
just makes me feel sick and I code that
in Kyle which I think it's free it's
really cool text editor with late export
other than that though I use Mendeley
for bibliography management which I find
phenomenally useful because you can
access your papers anywhere and it
generates a bibliography for you to
worry about like the tech link I also
use Dropbox to keep hold of all my code
and it acts as version control and also
means I can work on stuff from anywhere
like I can work on stuff from home or in
the office and or if I'm really
desperate I can check a figure on my
phone then in addition to those which I
like the meat herbs kind of what what I
use I tried using todoist which is a Tom
Frank recommendation I finally just
isn't really to me then I'm going to
have me terribly productive business and
maybe I should be reusing it I prefer
manuals dualists but you know when I
used it it was useful along with an app
called tomato time I think it was called
as I Pomodoro Technique which isn't out
though used for a bit I include links to
all these down there if you want to
check them out again that I'm not using
at the moment but in the past that's
work for me slack is another app
actually that the team here uses where
the whole research group is on a slack
and there are different channels for
like you know if you have a coding
problem if you have
like requests look through something
like a bit physics and that's quite
useful
Ashley and I feel like that like a slack
is pretty pretty cool service but but I
know is that professional thing did you
use slack but that's kind of it as far
as software goes you know there's only
so many things you can do to boost your
productivity and the other day for me it
comes down to writing computer code
which represents physics so in order to
do that I use sublime that's basically
what all my time is spent in also but
the have many times along to this
question yes I use a bun - this is free
and I only had a certain budget for my
laptop I don't have to pay for a license
and also because it's a chance to learn
the operating system and this way I'm
much more versed in sort of how
computers work with Windows your is a
little bit insulated from it so yeah I
use a bun too and it's not a dual boot
it's it's just pure free stuff seriously
though what the hell is going on here
you're in too much
I mean you Matt you spatially match but
what the hell is this I want 300 degrees
not 9600 come on it's a long day so I'm
gonna get an early night very early
thanks dad real old JK we're going up
Steven you guys gasp yieee Rampal the
Red October currently we're at DEFCON
soon
simply register super-tiny my phone
really doesn't like this like so we'll
cut to us talking about film after it's
happened now what did you think ah I
thought that was really really good
I think I enjoyed that more one of the
things that I said that took Simon by
surprise on the walk home was the last
midnight experience we had in that very
screened ya was Rohan yeah yeah and I
thought this was much better just as a
view it's you mean you likened it to
comparing apples and oranges because
they're very different films so you have
a film's totally different visually
different as a you know storytelling
completely different however if you kind
of I the way I did it was I kind of
dulled it down and basically said
without analyzing it and thinking too
much about it you go to the cinema to
view something that you enjoy ideally
you want a piece of entertainment right
and this was more enjoyable I just I
found it I felt more I laughed more
everyone I am more I'm Groot
like a parent yeah yeah I mean I think
it was a good film it wasn't great as we
had a because for full disclosure we
live like two minutes from the cinema so
on a brief walk back we already agreed
that yeah wasn't great but it was good
but also that parts of components of it
were excellent I think the human
particular mean I was laughing
a lot yeah I I would I mean without they
might change my opinion after kind of
giving it more but coming out at the
moment I give it I score it pretty
comfortably with a 7.9 so yeah the issue
I found interesting Lee that you you
said that you felt there was a
inconsistency in tone which I understood
I think that given its guardians of the
galaxy Tony it's so it's such a broad
spectrum of stuff you know that's what
makes it so great to watch but the only
thing that I felt for me was the pacing
was a little might have been a little
bit off in that you know in the final
the final third of the film
felt way way fast it's like they were
trying to kind of tie up loose ends
really really quickly and you know like
Bam Bam Bam Bam you know I felt like the
whole thing with the pacing was I liked
the whole film was stretched actually I
felt like there wasn't enough material
to cover a full film they were you know
what should we end this bit in the vlog
now if should we just film a whole
segment expunging electric let me just
talk about the film for 15 minutes yeah
okay all right we're gonna load this on
Spungen electric you want to see that
there's a link that's our second channel
by the way will there's a link down that
standard it me personally I love the
show
[Music]
[Music]